- Avec son nouveau plan,
la Ville de Montréal a
l'intention de mieux desservir
les quartiers laissés-pour-
compte, comme Montréal-Nord.
- On n'en a pas depuis
42 ans à Montréal-Nord!
- Trois nouveaux tronçons
du REV, du Réseau express vélo,
devraient être implantés
sur Jean-Talon, Henri-Bourassa
et Lacordaire, tous situés
au nord de l'île de Montréal,
moins garni en pisles.
C'est 200 km de voies cyclables
qui s'ajouteront aux 800 km
existants, un investissement
d'une valeur de 30 millions $
par an. Avec sa Vision Vélo,
Montréal veut offrir plus
de prévisibilité aux usagers
de la route.
- On le voit, en ce moment,
le stress que la fermeture
de la moitié du tunnel
a occasionné.
- Et la Ville s'engage à bien
consulter la population et ce,
avant chaque première pelletée
de terre.
SOPHIE MAUZEROLLE, et
de la mobilité Ville de Montréal
- L'idée, c'est vraiment
de travailler avec la société
civile, donc faire preuve de
flexibilité pour sue,
quand on déploie un chantier,
on n'est pas en train de générer
plus de problèmes que d'autres.
- Vélo Québec salue
l'initia
JEAN-FRANÇOIS RHEAULT,
pdg Vélo Québec
- Ce qui est très important,
c'est de relier les quartiers
qui n'ont pas nécessairement
de liens cyclables. On va parler
de Parc-Extension, Saint-Michel,
Montréal-Nord...
- Et certains de ces liens
cyclablecyclablecyclablecyclable
de commerces, ce qui peut amener
son lot de frictions.
AMOKRANE AKIR, propriétaire,
boulangerie Les deux blés- Les e
de s'arrêter sur le bord ici.
Donc, j'imagine que s'il y a
une piste cyclable,
ça va réduire l'espace
de stationnement.
- Ou plus de clients,
selon certains.
NATHALIE LEBOEUF, propriétaire,
Toilettage Calimousse
- Ça va faire plus de gens,
des gens qui vont passer.
Ça fait longtemps, par exemple,
qu'ils nous disent qu'il va y
avoir une piste cyclable, puis
a toujours pas vu, là.
- Dans tous les cas,
la collaboration de tous semble
nécessaire pour arriver à la
meilleure cohabitation possible.
FATIMA GABRIELA SALAZAR GOME
Assoc. mobilité sécuritaire
- Vous avez des besoins,
les automobilistes; nous avons
des besoins, les cyclistes;
les jeunes ont des besoins,
fait que c'est vra
de pouvoir rassembler
tout cet écosystème-là.
- Ici Gabrielle Proulx,
Radio-Canada, Mo